[Music]
oh
hi
i'm david hewlett i play dr rodney mckay
on stargate atlantis and i'm here to
take you behind the gate the secrets
revealed
stargate atlantis stargate sg1 the first
mystery that i'm about to reveal to you
people first time today is that space is
in fact a giant elvis painting blown up
really just from the groin region
thus to give you the vast expanse of
space
mystery one solved
[Music]
i see you guys got the vip switch
behind the gate is going to answer every
single question you've ever had about
sg-1 stargate atlantis we're going to
take you behind the scenes for example
behind these doors lies
oh come on who parked the jumper here
let me put up with the antics of those
kinds of you know actors with the hours
that you guys put in i don't know how
you don't scoop around all day here's
the leader there
swimming you guys you guys well you know
i meant the ghost guys
not you
this is how we have to prepare for
scenes hearing this running dialogue in
the
but this background in particular we're
uh
current timeline alternate timeline
we're present day
we're back 5000 years
and in our alternate timeline and this
affects us now
[Music]
for example we're going to see
the families really that have that have
grown up in the sg-1 environments and
stargate atlantis environments i mean
you know how we just we interact as a as
one big happy happy family
we have footage of that right we got
some footage of that
wait we're gonna show you guys how we
greet each other in the morning good
morning
there's a slice of stargate
look give me a damn chicken enchilada
um uh
uh
sir let me ask you some questions while
we're here interacting all right
friends you know fan to we have actually
got
live from the web questions from you to
us
if ancients have no body how could the
wraith hurt them
what are you guys smart atlantis
can you try to do better than that jack
and sam only kill pete
wow let me think about that for a second
what would be the perfect ending
um the credits so you want to know
what's behind the gate
nothing
got to be way back those wins outside
have blown that 110 knots we're not
going anywhere
[Music]
god i miss going off world
oh
[Music]
hey how y'all doing it's rainbow son
franks i play lieutenant aydin ford on
stargate atlantis and um it's a
beautiful day
in the place where both stargate
atlantis and sg1 are filmed talking
about vancouver doesn't get any more
beautiful than that
hey you remember dude from late night
with conan o'brien he goes by the name
of pierre bernard
[Applause]
there's this show on the sci-fi network
called stargate sg1 probably the best
sci-fi show since star trek bottom line
america
stargate sg1 is way better without dr
daniel
jackson he's going to be on set with us
asking all sorts of questions who knows
what he'll ask us but you're going to
see right here on the low down take you
behind the gate
good afternoon hi how are you doing all
right what can i do for you yeah my name
is pierre bernard i'm here to do some
interviews with stargate
yeah i'm going to be what are you
supposed to see i'm going to see all the
cast members i'm doing interviews for
stargate behind the scenes secrets
reveal okay i don't have your name here
at the gate
i'm gonna see richard dean anderson
amanda tappings chris judge you know
who's clearing you to come on the lot
not really i just assumed they were
gonna let me on in
okay can you just hold on a minute sure
sure
this is gonna be great
sometimes i feel like margaret hamilton
wicked witch
here's a secret about richard nina
anderson he was a mime artist i insisted
on talking
as the talking mime which is you know
the
cardinal sin of
miming it was too hard to
to communicate just
there's a wall here
you know do that kind of thing i'm
pulling a rope
now it's a big rope you know
[Music]
okay good it wasn't a career it was
something i had to do to live
you've got three minutes
before i shoot you as an intruder in my
home i worked for a magician did a kind
of a little road show for him that would
that was sponsored by burger king that
was always a nightmare right because you
would have to don this massive
molded
burger head
and your arms would be down like this
and you'd have to do everything else and
you couldn't see anything there's a mesh
that would get clogged with leaves and
bugs and drool might
anyway all right that wasn't necessary
hey guys
i'm back
thanks
you haven't seen amanda by any chance
have you
oh great great
[Music]
it says no caller id
can i answer that yeah okay hello
hello
oh hi sweetie
i'm good how are you
um but guess what i'm in the middle of
an on-camera interview
okay i still have to listen to it
yes but i have to call you back about
those appointments
no because i have to call you back
because i'm literally on an
on-air camera interview
[Music]
hi
so
secrets revealed you just got a secret
that was revealed you're not a single
and available it's the new york times
constantly at all times in between
between scenes he always and if you look
closely
if there was a false edit you'd see it
in the back of the back of his pants at
all times that's something really
strange well two papers new york times
and wall street journal read both of
them each day
well if i drink coffee and read the new
york times i'm so
agitated
by the time i'm finished with both of
them that i'm actually awake is carter
letting herself get too involved in this
one i do not believe colonel carter
would allow these feelings to interfere
with the commission of her duties fair
enough
but when the time comes
i want you to finish the job understood
i think
is really enjoying uh assimilating into
uh
the earth dating scene and uh i think
he's getting more attuned to the game
um
last i heard he was just out buying some
spinners for his truck so i think he's
fitting right in now there's been a
progression of teok becoming more and
more uh you know human basically uh
the idea was that a lot of the things
he's been doing were related to rituals
that were jafar rituals and the the
farther away he gets from believing in
those
doctrines the less he feels compelled to
you know adhere to them do whatever you
guys want to do
you need that for anything i see moving
is going to get shot
so what if it's a major then he'll get
hit with a race stunner instead of a p90
what if he sees us fast he'll probably
hear you first you tell me to shut up
again
again one of the big secrets about
atlantis is in the fact that our friend
dr beckett is not
scottish actually i am scottish david
he's not he's not scottish he's irish uh
i'm not irish conan's irish
lovely handsome man no by the way as
david mentioned earlier in the barbarian
[Applause]
[Music]
it's a brisk walk away
and by brisk you mean
farmer go by walk i mean
i think he's doing some great work you
know for a guy who's not done a lot of
uh clothes acting roles yeah i think
he's done some great i it's got time for
another scot in the sky yeah
that's really good
so okay um
there's a death
there's uh
a kiss
touch each other in the forbidden way
the forbidden way they're touching and
kissing and cuts
there's a major discovery i see that
they've lined the corners the edges with
the dirt that's important to you
sometimes we we get tightly reined in
because we uh we mess about a bit too
much or we laugh too much or
you know especially if we have a big
shooting day and and we can't stop
laughing then
but then they get nervous for the most
part everyone has a great time and we
all laugh together but every once in a
while it's okay we've got 11 pages to
shoot
chill out
fire on that target
i have to tell you that going into the
latter half of the the season i'm
just exhausted all the time that's
something that i have to get used to is
that such long hours and and for such a
long period of time i'm not used to
working like that on one side it's given
me
a place to live that isn't with my
parents and being the youngest guy it's
kind of cool for me and giving me a
whole new life experience that way
no it's wednesday
[Music]
secrets that daniel jackson has
yeah he's a crossdresser where's
everybody else
i transported them onto the elk
well you kept the wrong guy because i
don't know anything about the ship
but you are very attractive
secretly um what ends up happening is
this episode where thiel comes over to
visit him and um daniel's um
impersonating ethel merman
as of late people have been making a lot
of fun of these oceans on set and i'm
not happy about that calling us dirty
little people so we're cleaning them up
we're cleaning them up because we are a
proud people i'm not about to put those
lives in jeopardy until i at least know
how you def
she adapted to the whole military aspect
of it much more than i thought she would
and i think that had to do with just
necessity once you're faced with the
evil race there isn't really a way to be
hippie and peace-loving about it so
that's kind of stopped in our tracks a
bit and had to rethink amanda i'm back
oh no he's back
oh my
i miss you so much i miss you so much
why is new york so far away
how is it
i'm telling you this is gonna be great
fantastic
[Applause]
this effects for
the eye
i don't think have honestly ever been
done in television before
there's one big difference between the
gate on stargate sg-1 and atlantis and
that is that stargate sg-1skate
hey wait a minute
this is plastic
atlantis is stargate
rubber
and this is the other fun thing about it
look up there
it's a wiggly stargate
fascinating facts that i know you're
[Applause]
set
i should put this back because they're
going to need to that's not what it
wants to
[Music]
this is the map
nobody's really sure what it stands for
except we think it stands for mobile
all-terrain laboratory platform although
we made it up so it doesn't really
matter it costs
85 000.
[Music]
[Applause]
being extra on this show is it's it's
really lovely uh
you know they're
treated top-notch they're it's raining
they're
provided cover
they're hungry they're provided
sustenance
yo you volunteered i'll give you five
bucks you can give me a good screen come
here come here
[Music]
ready for you
hi i'm finn michael
i stand in for richard dean anderson on
the show
a lot of people don't know what a
stand-in does on this show we
do pretty well everything
half the time first thing in the morning
he's not there yet so i'm doing the
blocking doing his dialogue
i don't get any fan letters because they
don't know about me out there but now
they will i hope
i'm hoping to get out to some of these
gate cons i i know that they'd love to
meet me
oh check this out
his script with his gum on it
and his lines are actually highlighted
no speaker jaffa
no habla
well one of the other secrets of working
on stargate is there's a lot of waiting
around
i've been on the show for six years i'm
only 27 years old i mean check it out
if it takes seven days to shoot an
episode
six and a half days of that is just
sitting around waiting for lighting to
be done i beg to differ with that being
in charge of lighting
you differently we're more we wait more
time for these guys to decide what they
want lit and how they're gonna shoot it
than it takes to light it by far
that is so not the case
let's settle this right now what are we
waiting for what are we ready
by the way
lighting's ready
um wonderful relationships working in
social with martin wood
peter deluise has a phenomenal sense of
humor and he understands from an actor's
perspective the process
but still
is a very fine technician
[Music]
okay sci-fi fans here's a big secret
revealed the set that i'm standing in
right now was built for almost two
million dollars and it's solid steel
it's it's engineered steel it's a huge
thing there's 60 to 70 thousand dollars
worth of lights in here what i'm going
to do right now is going to walk you
through the set to show you how many
times in a single show i can use any
room any number of times so what ends up
happening like this area and here you
may notice from the
the season
opener there's thor's um console right
down there you throw it in the middle of
this thing you've got a huge asgard ship
this is where we put the wraith when we
want to keep them in atlantis raised in
atlanta as you might ask
now the show you're about to see called
the eye the beginning of this season
this is completely flooded this area in
here and there's so much water dumping
on them because there's a hurricane
happening right out there
hard to believe because that fedex truck
would be like in the middle of the ocean
somewhere but there's a big green screen
that we pull across in that thing and
that's how we make outdoors it's no
secret ever see guaranteed
[Music]
the biggest secret is
is that all of our visual effects are
actually done in this crappy crappy
building
we've been in there for eight
average age of a lot of the artists that
we have it really varies
but to be honest a lot of them are quite
young a lot of the guys there may be
like one of them's 19 a couple of them
21 they're living at home with their
mothers
without these guys you know i'd be out
of work that's for sure so it's it's
fantastic it's lucky for us
these are all
finished shots for a new episode of
hurricane atlantis called the eye
and
this stuff all had to do with this big
hurricane that was sweeping across the
ocean towards the city and it's finally
reached us vis effects for
the eye
i don't think have honestly ever been
done in television before
uh just features have done day after
tomorrow level visual effects in the
past the ancients have been protected by
the shield or submerged deep enough in
the water not to be affected flooding
could sink the city entirely
we treat stargate atlantis like a
feature
as best we can for an episodic
television series so
you know the model of the city when we
first built it was over four million
polygons well that's feature film size
you know that has enough detail that we
can back up and the city looks really
nice but if we had to we could get right
up beside the buildings and there's
still the amount of detail
and most of that's modeled not textured
so that if you turn around the city you
can actually see all the detail moving
[Music]
this is all software
every time we buy something to install
on a computer it usually comes on cd and
some of these cds when we got them you
know this would have been cutting edge
stuff when it arrives in the mail or by
courier
so some of these disks were in the
hundred thousand dollar range when they
came and now they're coasters but we
like to collect coasters so we have a
coaster display the largest one i'm
aware of
[Music]
carter is hot
zoom in on that hey look at me
[Music]